senator ted cruz of texas is leading a
tour to the border this friday and has
written a letter to president biden
pleading with him to let reporters come
along
and part of the letter reads as such
your administration clearly and
emphatically refused to offer press
access
this is outrageous and hypocritical end
quote
i want to bring in now senator cruz
republican from texas
joining me now senator welcome to the
program
first of all you know the lieutenant
governor dan patrick
has told me the same thing reporter's
not welcome to come and that was weeks
ago
what is going on what is it that we
can't see what what don't they want us
to know
well it's a crisis that's unfolding it's
getting worse and worse every day
it is the direct result of political
decisions made by the biden
administration as soon as joe biden was
sworn in
he halted construction on the border
wall he reinstituted the failed policy
of catch and release so they're really
releasing illegal immigrants who are
detained now they're doing that many in
many cases without covid testing them
and and he repealed the remaining mexico
policy which was a tremendous foreign
policy and immigration victory
that the trump administration had
negotiated with mexico
joe biden tore that apart and and the
result is we're seeing a crisis
last month over a hundred thousand
illegal aliens
were detained at the border and and it's
getting worse we're seeing in particular
more and more kids
unaccompanied kids young children kids
in cages as the media told us for for
four years relentlessly during donald
trump
well there are a lot more kids in cages
right now and the biden administration
doesn't want anyone to know this and so
on friday
i'm taking 17 senators down to the
border to meet with border patrol
to see the detention facilities to visit
with law enforcement
to hear the concerns down on the border
in texas i've spent a lot of time down
there
and astonishingly the biden
administration is refusing to allow
any media to accompany us uh we had
requests
fox news wanted to come with us abc news
wanted to come with us
in bed with us and and the
administration's argument it's really
quite absurd
is that apparently the media you guys
are too much of a risk
of covid that's their stated
justification never mind
that they are packing thousands upon
thousands of illegal immigrants
in packed facilities it is reporters and
cameramen that propose the kovid
uh coveted threat and harris that's
obviously absurd
i can tell you i've taken border trips
i've been to those facilities many times
in the obama administration in the trump
administration and they've always let
media in it is only the biden
administration
that is engaged in this blackout well
look there is another
type of spread and that is hypocrisy
and a lack of transparency and so that
is also what
you know they don't want us to see i
would imagine a couple of questions for
you though because i really want to
understand the logistics of this
so our reporter just said that 150
people at least that we know about could
be more
right have not had court dates set that
that's usually what happens you come
over the due process starts
and then they give you a date you report
so on and so forth so that we can keep
up with people we're doing a
call us back reach back mode yeah how
much of that is happening
well it's catch and release which
they've implemented in place and you
combine that with ending the remaining
mexico policy so
many the majority of those crossing the
border illegally are not from mexico
many of them are from central america
and they travel illegally through mexico
and what the trump administration
negotiated with the government of mexico
is that if they file an asylum
application in the united states
that they remain in mexico while that
case is pending the biden administration
decided they didn't want to do that
instead they wanted to release them
they're releasing many of them
in my home state of texas and i'll tell
you harris in harlingen texas
the rate of covet positive cases among
the illegal immigrants that they're
releasing
is more than seven times greater than
the rate in the u.s population
it is indefensible and it is a public
health risk
and the biden administration it's why
they don't want the press to know about
it they're trying to cover up
this crisis and it's self-created it is
joe biden
that has created this crisis so
and i i'm going to ask my team to put up
uh vice president kamala harris because
i do want to get your response to this
just as she seemingly laughed off a
question from a reporter who asked
yesterday if she would be visiting the
border amid the growing migrant crisis
here's
the vice president do you plan to visit
the border
um not today
[Laughter]
but um i have before and i'm sure i will
again we were left with a very
challenging situation
we've got to treat this issue in a way
that is
reflective of our values as americans
and do it in a way that
is fair and it is humane
senator cruz yesterday former president
trump told me they were not left
with the situation that democrats say
that they were they had a transition
and we can get into detail at another
time about that but your reaction
well i i got to say watching that
footage i served with kamala a number of
years in the senate and to see her just
laugh at this crisis at the border to
see her laugh at
these children it is a humanitarian
crisis that we've
right now got thousands upon thousands
of little boys and little girls
being handed over to human traffickers
who are physically abusing those kids
they're sexually abusing those kids
and the attitude of kamala and joe biden
is they're laughing at them
that is not compassionate that is not
giving a damn
i'll tell you the donna facility the
processing facility in texas
it right now has nearly 4 000 illegal
immigrants
in that facility it has a capacity of
250.
so it's it's 1500 times
in excess of its capacity and the
reaction of the byte administration and
kamala harris is just to laugh
and and to keep making it worse they
still won't fix it
i actually don't care if she laughs or
not what i care about
is stop making the problem worse stop
releasing people who are coveted
positive
stop putting kids in harm's way and stop
releasing criminals
that prey on the community well and if
you factor
the pandemic that we're in the health
crisis that we're in right now
they have created an international super
spreader event
at facilities along our border
endangering
everybody they're terrified that the
people trying to get
pictures and images of it that's exactly
right
yeah the gag order i'm curious if
congress can investigate that i'll bring
you back on another day
i want to dig deeper because i i have
never seen this kind of power
excised in this country to keep us
gagged
fox news is willing to speak about it
but the fact that every
news station is not outraged if donald
trump had done this and said no
reporters are allowed on the border
the media would have rightly lost their
minds and y'all would have been right to
right now too many of the reporters in
the mainstream media they view their job
as being
cheerleaders for the biden
administration and apologizing for it
i think the media has a right to be
there and and i'm fighting for the media
to be able to go
and see what's happening and get
pictures and and and see the crisis
that's happening and do our jobs
right that's exactly right senator ted
cruz of the great state of texas thank
you for your time perspective and we'll
follow as much as we can as closely as
we can what you do
at the border thank you